As we all know, Kevin is
one of the biggest movie stars
in the business right now,
and he deserves it.
He struggled for years.
When he finally got
his first big paycheck,
he spent $150,000
on a watch.
I forget that term for that.
It's not
"African-American rich."
It'll come to me.
[cheers and applause]
Justin,
you know the word.
I know you're all wondering
why I'm here tonight.
It's because Martha Stewart
changes people's lives
for the better,
like Shaq for instance.
When Shaq bought his house--
Shaq, are you listening?
I was the first person
he called.
The house had 13 bedrooms,
and I helped convert 8 of them
into refrigerators.
I believe the bedroom
is the most important room
in the house, but I don't
have to tell you that, Ludacris.
You have three kids
with three different women.
May I suggest pulling out
sometime, and finishing
on some fine, highly absorbent
Martha Stewart bed linens?